this girl I met on the airplane she was
blind and she couldn't see outside at
the sky and the sunset that was going on
but she felt the heat of it so she was
just asking me what it looked like so I
had to describe it to her so I remember
her because I appreciate sight because
of her
one time I was working a part-time as an
Uber driver and I picked up this man I
remember him telling me how many people
died Vietnamese died in the Vietnam War
because of what had happened he had to
go to training and like right when he
was done with training was like the
second they stopped the war so he didn't
have to go he said you know
sometimes people are very lucky I was a
very lucky man and he said sometimes not
so lucky and I was dropping him off at a
cancer center it's always stuck with me
and he was a very lovely man and I'll
always remember him to this day I just
wish that I had stayed with him because
I don't think anyone was there with him
for his cancer treatment that's what I
wish to this day